this video is brought to you by let's
get checked what's up guys Michael here
so I just finished the final season of
FX is mind blowing series Legion and
walked away with well a lot of thoughts
and that's a good thing it's the story
of David Haller and almost all powerful
ESP fueled mutant who also happens to be
a schizophrenic and it leans hard into
the nonsensical bizarre and just plain
weird it's got multiple reality bending
scenes wild off-the-wall musical numbers
and dance offs and with the addition of
season three time travel they're also
pretty self-aware about it too with
episode recaps often starting like this
evidently humbly gee ostensibly on
Legion but with so much going on it's a
little hard to pry out one coherent show
defining philosophy which always gets us
asking is the show smart or does it just
think it is well that's what we're here
to find out
welcome to this episode on Legion deeper
down and ostensibly spoilers ahead but
before we get into it I want to give a
shout out to let's get checked in at
home Testing Service with the mission to
make health screening open and patient
led if you're anything like me you know
that it's almost impossible to carve out
time to go to the doctor they're
available appointments always seem to be
on Wednesday at 2:00 p.m. on the other
side of town still I know how important
it is to keep tabs on my health one test
almost everyone I know is afraid to take
is a sexual health check
in fact 51 percent of people don't get
tested for STDs because they don't want
to bring up sex with their doctor enter
let's get checked
let's get checked offers a variety of
general wellness tests for men and women
which includes things like fertility
test hormone tests and STD tests it's
really important to make sure that you
get tested and with let's get checked
you can skip that awkward visit to the
doctor and do it right from the comfort
of your own home you just go online
order the kit and it will be delivered
in a discreet package within a few days
then you activate it online follow the
instructions and send back your sample
with a prepaid label once your results
are available online a let's get check
team of physicians and nurses are
available to discuss your results on the
phone and can prescribe medication when
appropriate you can get your own STD kit
or explore all their kit options today
by clicking the link
in the description or by clicking here
if you use promo code wisecrack you can
get 20% off now back to the show first a
quick primer on the show and yeah try to
keep up
season 1 introduces us to David Haller
who his whole life has been told that
he's insane but after being rescued from
the government's grasp by a group of
like-minded mutants David learns that he
actually has psychic powers and begins
training to control his power the only
problem is that a powerful telepath
Amahl Farouk has been lodged in his
brain since he was a baby and is now
trying to take over his mind while
season 1 ends with Farouk being kicked
out of David's brain season 2 focuses on
the group trying to kill him except not
really because we learned that David is
actually kind of an evil [ __ ] not
above torture and a friend to get what
he wants or raping his girlfriend's
Sidney Barrett and one of televisions
biggest bait and switches season 2 ends
with the group of friend in Farooq and
hunting David fast forward a few months
were season 3 picks up David has decided
to live a quiet life as a cult leader
for young women with abandonment issues
we my people become you talking about
your commune where you seduce teenage
girls with daddy issues that is until
the Time Traveler's switch arrives but
David's not interested in going back in
time and writing his wrong instead he
wants to go so far back in time that he
stops
Amahl Farouk from ever inhabiting his
brain in the first place and the process
stopping all the literal madness that
has occurred since the only problem is
that switches powers aren't fully
developed yet am i going so far back in
time david has angered some seriously
creepy baddies in the Hall of time there
are demons demons still David and switch
keep at it which causes some disastrous
consequences for the present like oh
right potentially ending the world while
Sydney and the others raised backwards
in time to stop David from doing any
more damage
David meets up with his father in the
past telepath Charles Xavier of x-men
Fame and teams up with him to kill
Farouk except future Farouk joins the
mix and convinces Charles that violence
isn't the answer after one touching
father-son moment and a slightly less
touching but still moving past
future Farouk moment everyone comes to
an understanding I'm saying that wool is
not the answer it's the problem David we
don't need this barbarism I've made a
deal with Farouk are you saying we just
leave I'm saying that we respect their
right to exist and they respect ours
yours with the past successfully changed
David and Sydney look over the crib but
baby David before they both disappear
into the ether having effectively erased
their own existences and scene now if
all of that doesn't seem perfectly clear
to you don't panic
from the get-go Legion has always been
about challenging the audience's
expectations and season three is no
different
simply put it's confusing what does it
all mean
well here's our two best takes ideal one
metaphor and metaphysics in case it
wasn't immediately obvious Legion
thrives on an ambiguous sense of reality
throughout the show's three seasons we
are constantly asking ourselves what is
real or true is David Haller really
David or is he the host of other
personalities inside his head how are
you I am
I am Legion is Amahl Farouk really evil
or is he actually a loving surrogate
father love the boys jobs as it turns
out much of this ambiguity stems from
the show's unabashedly for metaphors but
when we say metaphor were not just
talking about simply comparing two
things but a very specific philosophical
sense of the word borrowing from the
work of philosopher Richard Moran we can
say that metaphors create a sense of
ambiguity because of the framing effects
they produce in Moran's view metaphors
forced people to consider an object or
situation in a new light by contrasting
it with another importantly this framing
isn't fixed nor is its meaning and this
is where our ambiguity creeps in when
the show calls farooq a monster for
example its cue mean anything from the
fact that he's technically an alien
life-form to the fact that he's
incredibly powerful to the fact that he
once trapped a king's mind inside that
of a monkey's by monster you mean like a
metaphor right as philosopher Donald
Davidson points out most metaphors don't
possess definite meanings any more than
dreams - after all when Romeo compares
Juliet to the Sun there are a million
and one different things it could mean
in the same way that dreaming you're
naked in front of your high school class
could mean both everything and nothing
but what's important here is that by
framing Juliet with the Sun we're
creating an infinite amount of
associations according to Davidson just
like in dreams a metaphors meaning is
interpretive at its best the dreamlike
logic behind metaphors really does drive
home how ambiguous legion's reality
really hits take season 2 and which
episodes often begin with an educational
segment that later contextualizes the
action on-screen psychologists call it a
conversion disorder
in that the body converts a mental
stress to a set of physical symptoms in
this case a tick or spasm and like any
disorder it can be contagious at first
these segments seem to contextualise
our understanding of the various
telepathic phenomenon going on in the
show the spread of our teeth clacking
zombies for example as compared to the
way conversion disorders like laughing
fits and mass hysterics have spread
throughout history and another segment
delusions are characterized like
parasites feeding on rational ideas
until only they are left this in turn
later explains the spread of the
delusion among the members of Division
three that an admiral must be killed
people go to Admiral Fukuyama's pedestal
and they don't come back in both cases
these metaphors seem to contain fairly
simple meanings madness is contagious
and delusion is destructive but of
course meaning is a moving target with
metaphors and reality is constantly
shifting under your feet in Legion while
we spend a whole season thinking we
understand what these metaphors mean the
last episode of season 2 really rips the
rug from underneath our collective feet
the madness that had been spreading the
delusion that had been growing it was
David and boy were we wrong
your treachery has been discovered the
inevitability of your future crimes
however while the end of season 2 might
have been a high point for legions
thematic use of metaphors season 3
demonstrates how sometimes the show can
collapse under a metaphors weight
because let's be real here some
metaphors like dreams make zero sense at
all
I think the best example of this would
be season three's depiction of the
astral plane as if it was purposefully
designed to give us a headache
the astral plane is both a literal and
metaphorical place Amahl Farouk at one
point gives us this no-nonsense
definition of it well at least by legion
standards this is
thus Robley a world beyond made of pure
energy the fuel meanwhile Jemaine oh I
mean
Oliver tells us that the astral plane is
kind of like the island of misfit toys
were broken mines forgotten truths and
lost objects all collect we will always
finding things pins poetry songs the
astral plane was like a magnet for lost
dreams mines that was the other thing we
found in the real world when people lost
their minds they ended up here on the
surface were presented with an
interesting problem
how can a metaphorical place where
literal lost dreams come true also be a
real place and what does this tell us
about the larger logic motivating Legion
well one way we could go about this is
to assume that both the physical and
mental properties are equally real in
the show.if thoughts and matter all
contains some for lack of a better word
mental stuff then it goes a long way in
explaining how a metaphorical world like
the astral plane can double as a real
physical place so for example while we
might usually think of being heartbroken
as an emotional state in the astral
plane you could literally find the
embodiment of your broken heart bleeding
out in the street forget you're by
having these mental states manifest
themselves physically in the astral
plane the show seems to be advocating
for a sort of pan psychic doctrine
distilled into its most basic component
pan psychic ism holds at the old
Cartesian divide between mind and body
isn't really a divide at all instead the
pan psychist believes that everything
from the glass in your smartphone to the
neurons in your brain contains
fundamental mental elements now before
you start worrying that the ground
beneath your feet has feelings
[Music]
pants I kissed usually don't commit to
the idea that everything has thoughts
instead most believe that everything has
a mental experience the mental
experience of a human might be quite
complex while that of a fly might be
much simpler and that of a rock would be
even more basic to most pants ICA's
mental experience is a fundamental
building block of the universe with
actual thought only being achieved by
sufficiently complex entities applying
this model to legion we can see all both
regular everyday objects and abstract
ideas like the loss of innocence appear
in the astral plane they all have a
mental experience it also goes a long
way in explaining like David struggles
to differentiate between his mind and
reality they're all made of the same
mental building blocks his mind his
reality ultimately but while this is an
interesting hook into the show it's hard
to say if the show is really using Pan
psychism or metaphors to make any deeper
arguments about the nature of reality or
experience when it comes to pants
psychism the show never seems to really
draw out any of the implications of
having reality and your mind being both
equally real especially in regards to
David and when it comes to metaphor it
sometimes feels like the show is
confusing for the sake of being
confusing sure in an oversaturated
superhero market it might be fun to see
musical numbers stand in for dialogue
there's only one way this can
a rap battle but sometimes we'd like to
understand the literal narrative after
all according to playwright and
screenwriter David Mamet the core of
drama is about finding previously
unsuspected meaning Paley's the truth
that had been previously obscured by
lots but maybe we should be okay with
legions uneven use of metaphor for a
show that's so out there in terms of art
direction maybe all the metaphors are
just a way to tell an interesting story
philosophy be damned going back to our
philosophers Moran and Davidson
metaphors don't have to necessarily make
sense the important thing is the effect
the framing and effect seems to be
legions mo it's all about that style so
maybe we should forgive the show for
pelting us with various dance numbers
loquacious asides it's about the owner
of things the order you learn when
you're a young we let you be wild
because wildness is important but is it
gold uh give you structure so you'd feel
safe and the very weird astral plane
maybe old legion is trying to do is keep
it interesting so deep maybe not
idea to time and change of course the
big shake-up in season three other than
Pathan amis mustache is the addition of
the time traveler switch now it might
seem unfair to put legions depiction of
time travel under the microscope when it
comes to comic book characters we kind
of just have to grant the initial
premise radioactive spiders giving you
superpowers instead of cancer sure why
not and early on Legion playfully
reminds us that its depiction of time
travel isn't going to trade you heavily
on science what do you know about time
travel I have a PhD in quantum mechanics
and a master's in nuclear physics have
you ever seen the hole the hole
time there's a hallway it moves in two
directions forwards and back and by
drawing a doorway in the air like this
I can access the timestream but there
has to be some internal logic going on
right well in legions case not really in
fact the final season continually fails
to address one of the biggest logical
problems in time travel the grandfather
paradox that is how can time travel be
possible if you went back in time killed
your grandfather and made sure you were
never born to go back and kill said
grandfather now there are a lot of ways
to tackle this problem you could go the
Marvel route and just say no matter what
you do while swatting around in the past
the future doesn't change time doesn't
work that way changing the past does it
change the future
as for Allegiant the show solution can
best be summed up as [ __ ] it come at me
bro
yeah so David does successfully change
his past by keeping his parents together
and saving his baby's self from Amahl
Farouk in doing so he literally erases
his current self so knowing we just sort
of fade away into the youth how does
this square with the fact that if David
hadn't shared his brain with fruit for
33 years he wouldn't have gone back in
time in the first place it doesn't but
maybe Legion isn't trying to make a
logical argument about time travel
maybe this aspect of the story as trippy
and sometimes nonsensical as it is is in
service of a larger message were brought
back to the idea of metaphor the
beginning of legions final episode
starts with this text flashing across
the screen this is the end the beginning
the end what it all means is not for us
to know it is for history to decide all
we can do is play the parts is written
all we can know is ourselves on the
surface of it it seems strange for
Legion to frame the final episode of the
quote after all if David and company are
just playing their parts as written how
are they supposed to change the past and
what does self-knowledge have to do with
well anything but what if this text is a
metaphor asking us to reframe everything
we've seen in three seasons according to
these words in this case the show hints
that everything david has done past and
present from being born to cartoon
fighting Amahl Farouk has been necessary
that David needed to quite literally
experience time in order for him to
change and thereby save the world and
while it might seem like we're reaching
here this theory does fit with the rest
of the show in fact the idea that
characters needed to experience time to
change is integral to all our major
players arc Sid for example must live a
second childhood in the astral plane
under the watch of Oliver and Melanie
she goes from being the understandably
rage-filled girl shooting her rapist to
a kick-ass self-actualized woman who
knows how to save the world I know honey
but here's the thing
the real world needs you all those bad
things they don't have to be bad it can
be fixed likewise the 30-plus years
Amahl Farouk spent in David's head has
changed him I saw what he saw I felt
what he felt I know that's what he
thought and over time what was once a
person became a person when present
Farouk finally sizes up his past self he
can barely contain the contempt for the
person he once was
yeah all day but what about David
does he really change according to our
girl Sid there's no saving the present
David he's broken goods
David adult David we can't save him he's
too far gone but a baby this baby him we
can save so how does time help David
change quite literally by unwrite
inhibits listen to this narration David
gives in the beginning of the final
episode again it serves to refrain
everything we've seen up to this point
in the show lessons in time travel
chapter zero who we were does not
dictate who we will be
but often it's a pretty good indication
[Music]
time travel does not give one the
opportunity to change oneself but rather
to eradicate oneself
and allow something else to form in the
wake of what once was
in other words change for David could
only come through destruction and he can
only achieve that destruction by messing
with time it's madness and it's a
complete twist on how other characters
experience time in order to change but
madness is David's mo finally in the
closing minutes of the show Legion seems
to suggest that there's almost a cosmic
plan to this change whether it's
Sydney's second childhood or David
suicide gamble when switch dies in the
final episode it's revealed that she's
not human at all but quite literally the
embodiment of time itself
I'm time I see all when switch returns
back to earth she lets everyone know
that there was meaning to the change
they underwent that switch as an
embodiment of time in the universe
itself has validated that Sidney Barrett
Gabrielle Xavier and the infant David
the universe acknowledges you that you
exist and that your existence is
important I can see that you've suffered
that people you love have suffered and
you want to know that it meant something
it did it does nothing of value is ever
lost and even though the present then
will perish
it was also better versions of
themselves shall flourish in their place
so what do we make of legions take on
time and change again I think it's best
to invoke Davidson's work on metaphor as
Davidson rightly points out how many
facts are conveyed by a photograph none
an infinity or one great unstable fat
bad question a picture is not worth a
thousand words or any other number words
are the wrong currency to exchange for a
picture in the same way
holding legions take on time and change
to a philosophical standard might not be
the right approach at the end of the day
Nowell Holly decided to not make a
philosophical argument with the show but
rather an artistic one and like in
time-travel in this choice there is a
sort of grace or madness whatever deeper
meaning there is here if any at all this
shows not giving us any hints overall we
give Legion a 5 out of 10 for Smart's
but it may be we're just not getting
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]